ما انا في الاستديو لواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه مرحبا بك
سيد فايز بالحديث عن حيث تتركز المعارك هل
يبدو ان الجانب الروسي اصبح اكثر اقتناعا
من خلال الاجراءات التي يتخذها اكثر
اقتناعا بامكانيه خساره هذه المنطقه او
جزء اساسي منها يعني هو بناء على ما سبب
من معارك بدءا من كيف مرورا بخار كيف
الايمان بغيرها
والدعوه الى همم تعبئه 300,000 بدع الجيش
الروسي يعاني ولم يعد قادرا على خوض
المعارك التعرضيه في المستوى العملياتي
وبالتالي بناء على هذه المقدمات يتم
البناء عليها الان همم الاجراءات التي
تتخذ من الجانب الروسي لا استطيع همم
والضفه في اتجاه واحد على سبيل المثال
بالامس كان هناك اشارات انزال العالم عن
بعض الدوائر همم اليوم في صباح هذا اليوم
تدمير بعض نقاط العبور تدمير بعد القوارب
اذا اخذت السكان تم اجلاء 70,000 من قبل
عده ايام اذا اخذت هذا الامر كاجراء عسكري
حقيقي انا كمخطط مقابل همم لا استطيع كسب
المعركه يجب ان اضع على اكثر من علامه
استفهام حول هذه الاجراءات هل هي تاتي ضمن
اطار خداع استراتيجي
بانه التنازل عن خرسون بدون معركه حاسمه
سيطرح الكثير من التداعيات اللاحقه في ان
يتحدث كمحلل واقول اذا تم التخلي عنها دون
خوض معركه حاسمه داعياتها علينا ان نقول
ما بعد خلصن ليس كما قبل الخرشوف بهذا
السبب لا اتوقع كمحلل ومتابع ان روسيا
ستتخلى عنها بكل هذه البساطه
سيكون هناك معركه لكن قد نختلف في تقييم
حده وحسم هذه المركبه في خير اذا اردنا ان
نتحدث باختصار عن نقاط القوه التي يملكها
الجانب الاوكراني في مقابل نقاط القوه
التي همم يملكها الجانب الروسي لمن تميل
الكفه برايه يعني الان لا نستطيع ان نعطي
نسبه لكن دعني اقول قد تتراوح النسبي ما
بين
40 الى 45% لصالح الجانب الروسي و50 الى
55% لصالح الجانب الاوكراني لماذا لانه
هناك العديد من العوامل التي تدعم الجانب
الاوكراني ليحقق التميز اهمها الدعم
الغربي باسلحه نوعيه متطوره في بعض
الفيديوهات اذا لاحظت استخدام قذائف
الهيمارس تستخدم بين بوي طريقه على اهداف
متحركه هذا الامر سبب الكثير من المشاكل
الامر الاخر همم الان همم
تخطيط العمليات للقوات الاخرانيه همم مبني
على الفكر الغربي انا هنا لا ادعم الفكر
الغربي بقدر ما اقول انه يستطيع ان يحدد
نقاط الضعف فانا اقرا المعركه الاتي هجمات
جمهوريه مع اختراقات معززه في التفاف من
الاجنحه هذا يفضي بالثاني الى عمليه
التطوير لهذا السبب لجات القوات الروسيه
من باب الحساب عدم الدخول في مخاطره
استراتيجيه قامت باجلاء السكان وتقوم
بعمليات التخفيف انا اقول المعكس ستحسم
لصالح اوكرانيا لكن ثمنها باهت شكرا جزيلا
لك اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكريه